hello that guy with the glasses here and
welcome to under the tree and this is
something I used to do a lot I used to
just go under the tree and look up at at
the lights and here if you turn around
yeah looks like we even decorate the
inside of the tree we're hardcore let
all those plugs holy crap
yeah care a lot about Christmas here so
under here we have all sorts of goodies
yeah look at all those gifts these are
some cool cool get what we got here
good take a look here this is a this is
to Doug from Rob aww is that actually I
know exactly what this is this is a
christopher walken action figure panel
and listen oh stop shaking me I'm a very
valuable toy yeah that that's definitely
a Christopher Walken action figure we
got some other stuff here too we got oh
this one's to my dad to my dad from Rob
let's see that's okay that was dad so
that that doesn't matter and hey
speaking of Rob I think I hear him Rob
why don't you come down the over-under
here come on come on did that things are
great under the tree hello hey hey
it's kind of cool under here it is
pretty cool you know more people should
do this they should go under the bill
this plugs and that's something right
we're totally gonna have this tree is
gonna burn down that's a fire hazard
waiting to happen
yeah we're gonna have a very hot flaming
fiery Christmas pretty much it's gonna
be it's gonna be hot to say that tree
this is this looks like a spooning with
Spoony episode 3 doesn't it that's three
words throw here no yes yes I won't fall
for that again you already did that's
true yeah once was enough for me so you
know I'm round here but we know you want
a half a gingerbread cookie really yeah
well we want do you want the head or the
crotch uh it's always the crotch for me
well there you go and I know you like
the head so well no actually the way I
eat these I like to eat every
first so that way it feels the most
amount of suffering oh okay no more I
finally eat its head
actually I'll also take off the torso
first good I heard when you chop the
head off from the torso that it can live
for like an extra 15 seconds and see its
own headless body
I think you've thought way too hard
about this probably probably yeah so uh
alright peach oak if you lay down eating
I know you can choke any time but is it
more probable if you do all the laying
down hopefully okay so wait you said you
wouldn't fall for the rohypnol thing
again you just did
oh really okay there's it's quite an
adventure coming later I'm sure so we
don't just treat this - yeah that's true
we're both gonna have both gasp sleep
very well tonight
well where's the fun in that I don't
know mmm
what will dream of sugar plums rohypnol
sugar plums in our heads and it will be
magnificent so um you know I think I see
them right now
enter semi this is cool I love rohypnol
Wow
I'm sorry I just dazed out there so yeah
let's say before but before we sign off
here there's someone wanna tell you Rob
very focus focus you ready yeah you
ready you ready I'll always be ready you
ready we just say it I love you I am I'm
not my joking like I just love you
you're a kick-ass brother I'm glad you
do know it like you helped with the
nostalgia critic help write them like
the most successful thing on the website
I just wanted to say you're a kick-ass
brother well you know what um two years
too late pal I want like a whole year
without any credits they'll thought it
was you that's my girl Ramona won't
Mashhad and Alice used to say they were
all history there's like it's the old
Doug show every is just like Oh Oh Doug
he's so great he does all this by
yourself he built a whole website by
himself he built channel awesomes evil
criminal empire and just evil criminal
yeah probably but it's okay be done at
then out okay I definitely will
so he built this mass-murdering evil
criminal empire by himself apparently
according to all the fans well i'm he
stepped on all the little people that
the fans can't be wrong done them
crushed their balls in his tiny little
fingers hmm
I don't know why he did that but why did
he do that rub because he doesn't have
any balls himself he needs all the balls
so I can have more than just two balls
I'll have like an army of balls now you
really have any to begin with no no if
I'm saying once I get everybody's balls
you know like Christmas ornaments gather
together in my crotch it's it's really
like Batman how he just fights all of
this insane amount of crime I'm fighting
about a balls you're you're gathering
all the balls because really just you
can't feed that gaping hole in your soul
okay so the balls are from my soul their
soul balls yeah okay Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas indeed but I might just
be saying that because I'm a little
drunk okay well it might be the rohypnol
as well no revenue well I don't think
that rohypnol and outcome ro Hall go
well together like really at all well
words we can write with always at all
rohypnol alcohol that go home kids in
the hall we've done it all y'all I think
we're just saying all over and over and
then that doesn't quite work it didn't
help that that eggnog kid ran the unit
that that's true that was very good I
didn't I didn't know that there was
alcohol in that yeah I mean I added a
quart of whiskey to it yeah that on top
of the brand new jersey i didn't know
there was brandy in it so I'm just like
well this is more alcohol than I'm used
to the quart of whiskey I could handle
was a guy I said I loved you so I mean
everybody would probably think I'm drunk
yeah no I think they think you're gay
really well gay and incest to it you
know incest cuz you're my brother
incestuously yeah yes exactly so you
heard right here that guy okay and
incidentally guests liked Christmas
guess which we're having over tomorrow
that that's true or you should show this
to them yeah oh I'm sure they were a lot
the family would love to hear about you
know rows in a row hypno alcohol hang oh
yes well what the hell if it's good for
however many viewers we got the website
I'm sure it's good to show our family as
well I'm sure they'll just love it
Jesus I'm an angry drunk yeah you are
you're very angry I'll spread gently
punch the camera right now I'm sorry
well it's way up there and with the
rohypnol it seems like it is law hard to
grab three miles away
whoa you look like you have three I'm
like mr. fantastic oh my god I think my
arms just stretch like a mile Wow oh you
look like a pumpkin right now I am a my
pumpkin I think you are now because of
the rohypnol no that doesn't work it's
Christmas I can't be a pumpkin I know or
to turn yourself into something else
quick I'm I'm I'm a Christmas present
I'm gonna do me Wow
yeah that's beautiful dude
well I think we're gonna enjoy our
rohypnol
sighs eyes self rehab no we hippin all
we need rohypnol rohypnol
Oh rohypnol somebody has to event we're
gonna invent that tonight rohypnol and
we're gonna tomorrow morning yes is
going to kick ass oh we also had to
invent a drink called soul balls soul
balls and rohypnol
will there be ruminant anything you want
man it's your dog needs wrong it's
whatever you think you're so rohypnol
yeah they'll definitely have a dog
that's right see he drove in the
rohypnol yes yes in brandy you know what
I think we should do right now I'm
talking about the girl brandy not the
drink she's still around Richie and
sister's sister said that brandy no um
think of those two booze wasn't brandy
in some sort of Disney Channel thing why
she I know people if you get with a name
like brandy she needs to be on like
three sheets or some show where she's at
bars but now yeah but if she was on a
Disney show or any show for that mayor
put it in the poopoo in the comments
because we're actually very curious
about that when she ever on Sister
Sister
I don't know this hat is eating my face
yes just in that way I think it it's
mine mine is keeping its distance
thankfully
so now brandy was on some sicko wait
wasn't it just called brandy maybe or
was I never saw it Tom
so he was on something you know where
the we like the nostalgia critic team we
should know these things
yeah that's true it wasn't that old oh
really I didn't give a shit about her
back man either yeah she was hot though
she was sad she's scared she's very cute
yeah what the hell she is now I don't
know you make like one of those great
like Santa's elves but not the show yeah
like creepy no no no like the tall hot
tall hot elves oh yeah I know mrs. Claus
doesn't like yeah yeah yeah you don't
seem a female elves do you that's
because they're tall and sexy and that
distracts a lot of that confuse all
along younger gay yeah all of them every
single one I don't know that yeah you
know you're actually pretty smart I am
pretty smart yeah that maybe they were
hip nog talking but oh so you're like
normally an idiot but the rohypnol
superzero
no it's like a five think I am very
smart actually I think no I'm starting
to think you're in it no no that's Thor
hip and all talking right now yo you
know that's just me being an angry drunk
and having a habit eats my face
seriously okay you know what because
this video has been going on for let's
try for a fifth time to wrap this up now
and let let's point at them these people
and wish them I'm gonna point super
Merry Merry Christmas Merry Christmas to
you and to you and to the dinosaur in
the right hand corner merry Christmas to
you I don't know there's lizard the
lizard people are over though the
dinosaurs no no I see a raccoon fairy
myself oh sweet raccoon fairy yeah
they're pretty odd I'm gonna go ask her
out okay later
you do that guys hey babies come here
often my brother uh you whore did that
shit not work oh she's totally like
Wow I'm asleep
all right I still love you and I'm still
an angry drunk people Merry Christmas
have a wonderful new year